do something you're very
passionate about
and
don't
try to chase
what is kind of the hot passion of the
day i think we actually saw this i think
you see it all over the place in many
different contexts but i think we saw it
uh in the internet world quite a bit
where you know at the sort of peak of
the uh sort of internet uh you know
mania and say 1999 you found people who
were
uh you know very passionate assuming
they kind of left that job and decided
i'm gonna you know do something in the
internet because it's you know it was
almost like the
you know the 1849 gold rush in a way i
mean you find that people if you go back
and study the history of the 1849 gold
rush you find that you know at that time
everybody who was in was within the
shouting distance of california
was you know they might have been a
doctor but they quit being a doctor and
they started panning for gold
and
that
that almost never works
and even if it does work
you know according to some metric
financial success or whatever it might
be i suspect it leaves you ultimately
unsatisfied so you really need to
be very clear with yourself and i think
one of the best ways to do that is this
notion of projecting yourself forward to
age 80 looking back on your life and
trying to make sure you've minimized the
number of regrets you have that works
for that works for career decisions it
works for family decisions um you know
do you want i have a
14 month old son and it's very easy for
me to if i think about myself when i'm
80 i know i want to watch that little
guy grow up
and so it's i don't want to be 80 and
think shoot you know i miss that whole
thing and i don't have the kind of
relationship with my son that i wished i
had and so on and so on want to be happy
build a life not just a business hey
it's evan carl michael and this channel
was created to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back a lack of belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and get some success
advice from the top and learn how
billionaires think
enjoy
lesson number two align your skills with
ai with elon musk over time ai will make
jobs kind of
pointless
probably the last job that will remain
we'll be doing
writing ai software
and then eventually the ai will just
write its own software
so
i don't know i suppose i would recommend
studying engineering physics that kind
of thing
or working on something where
people just want to interact with other
people
and people enjoy fundamentally
interacting with other people so if
you're working on something that
involves
people or
engineering it's probably
a good approach
you know art of course
yeah
like i said i think we're going to have
to figure out this
neural link situation
otherwise
we will be left behind
um
it's very important we do this quickly
lesson number three serve with oprah
winfrey all of you know the story of how
this great school came to be how the
stanfords lost their only child to
typhoid at the age of 15.
they had every right and they had every
reason to turn their backs against the
world at that time but instead they they
channeled their grief and their pain
into an act of grace
within a year of their son's death they
made the founding grant for this great
school pledging to do for other people's
children what they were not able to do
for their own boy
the lesson here is clear and that is if
you're hurting you need to help somebody
else ease their hurt
if you're in pain help somebody else's
pain and when you're in a mess you get
yourself out of the mess helping
somebody out of theirs and in the
process you get to become a member of
what i call
the greatest fellowship of all the
sorority of compassion and the
fraternity of service the stanfords had
suffered the worst thing any any
mom and dad can ever endure yet they
understood that helping others is the
way we help ourselves and this wisdom
is increasingly supported by scientific
and sociological research it's no longer
just woowoo soft skills talk
there's actually a helper's high
a spiritual surge you gain from serving
others so if you want to feel good you
have to go out and do some good
but when you do good i hope you strive
for more than just the good feeling that
service provides because i know this for
sure that doing good actually makes you
better
so whatever field you choose
if you operate from the paradigm of
service
i know your life will have more value
and you will be happy
i was always happy doing my talk show
but that happiness reached a depth of
of a
of uh of joy
that i really can't describe to you a
measure
when i stopped just being on tv and
looking at tv as a job and decided to
use t television to use it and not have
it use me
to use it as a platform to serve my
viewers
that alone changed the trajectory of my
success
so i know this that whether you're an
actor you offer your talent in the way
that most just inspires art if you're an
anatomist you look at your your gift
as knowledge
and service to healing
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there lesson number four live life to
the fullest with richard branson one
time when you were doing hot air
ballooning you weren't sure whether you
would survive with the ballooning
adventures i was doing something that um
that nobody had done before
i was
you know trying to you know fly across
the atlantic or the pacific or or go
around the world in a in a balloon
i was flying at you know 40 000 feet in
in the jet stream um you know with one
with one other person pure lynn strand
um
uh
and
you know the technology was completely
unproven they were
we were the test pilots that was more
dangerous things could go wrong and they
did go right you set a number of
guinness world records for that but in
hindsight you have any regrets about
taking those risks
on the hot air balloon
it's interesting um you know my son and
daughter now
uh
are setting themselves big adventures
every year um dragging their dad along
on some of them you know and i think as
a family we feel
you know live life live life to its full
and
um and you know you you can
uh you know you can
uh you can you can die in a road
accident you can die on just a normal
bike ride and and quite often when
you're actually
completely focused on an adventure um
the
it's less likely in some way that you're
going to die
in an adventure because you're you're
ready and sharp and
and know how to deal with it lesson
number five have a dream with bill gates
a long time ago 1991 i gave a speech
called information your fingertips and
we sort of have it in a low level sense
that it's all online and if you can
write sql statements you know which
database and you have the right
permission
uh
you know it's there or well now some of
it's in other forms of database so maybe
you need to know three or four query
languages but
uh you know how far away are we from
letting you utter
a
what any information worker might
typically want to ask about finding an
expert or the history of an account or
the sales in this region versus the
sales in that region and engage in in a
dialogue on that i think we are
extremely close to being able to do that
and
you know that's
that's pretty fantastic it's you know
kind of nice to see some of the original
dreams come true
you know there is a dream about
really understanding text in a deep
sense that i have no idea how quickly
we'll get to that but i do think in the
next five years
the semantics of tasks and natural
language navigation all of all of over
all of the company's information in a
rich way and having an agent participate
in the meeting that kind of listens and
even kind of passively can put things up
on the screen that might be of relevance
or can be told explicitly to go get
something and bring that into the
conversation it's keeping the transcript
i mean that kind of demo that you know
has been done for decades uh that thing
will be real i mean people actually want
to use it and the amount you'll have to
charge them is so little uh that it it
might almost be the default way of doing
things lesson number six have the right
investment priorities with grant cardone
property's been a big part of your
career in investing in property
what you know can you just give us an
insight into do you still think that
that's a good investment for you because
i know you've been on record as saying
you know it's not a good idea to to to
own your own house that kind of thing
where you know what what are your views
on the current uh property market so so
the issue the issue for property again i
love real estate you know we buy real
estate every day every day i'm
trying to buy some real estate
but the problem is priorities people
god gets out of school
gets married husband and wife oh we got
to buy a house that is the wrong first
thing to do like why are you buying a
house
we need a place to live that's an
investment a house is not an investment
a business is an investment
uh going to dinner with a client that is
an investment
going on a trip to meet with other great
people that could become investors or
customers that's an investment buying a
house a place to live
and the banks the banks years ago the
banks convinced the public that
uh
a house is an investment a house is not
an investment
so why are people notice how many of
your friends bought a house but they
have invested money in their in their in
their business
they bought a house but they didn't
invest money in making themselves done
dude i am the house
it's the grant cardone house
okay where i live doesn't really matter
to me it could be the ritz hotel it
could be the four seasons it could be
the marriott
it could be your house i could go bunk
up at your place
the investments people should be making
is number one in myself number two is in
my business and the third thing they
should buy once they got the first two
handled
everybody should start trying to invest
in real assets or real estate that pays
them i'm not talking about a house i'm
talking about
buy
buy a piece of real estate that other
people rent
from you
so that you get cash flow and lesson
number seven the last one before some
very special bonus clips is desire
success with tillman fertitta i always
wanted to succeed
you know do i wish i wouldn't have
dropped out of college because i was
making money because i only had like 32
hours to go
yeah but you know what but now i'm the
longest-running chairman of the board of
regents of that university so it really
doesn't matter doesn't matter exactly
exactly so but but but that bothered me
for a long time that i never finished
school but then as you become more and
more successful and you see all these
other guys in the forbes 400 too that
never finished school because because
there's something in us
that we just can't we can't have those
handcuffs on it we we're making money
and we i can't deal with going to class
i gotta i gotta make money and when i
was 21 years old i was already making
you know a couple hundred thousand a
year
that's big money big money back and what
this is
yeah the early eighties wow that's big
money big money you know and people
don't realize that when you say i was
making a couple hundred thousand dollars
but that was big money huge big money
your brain does not want you to hit your
dreams your brain
is designed to keep you small to keep
you safe to keep you protected your
heart wants to create amazing things
your heart has big dreams your heart
sees a beautiful world and says i want
to go make something better and then you
wake up the next day
and your brain takes over and says you
can't do that
that's too risky that's too dangerous
stay small stay safe you didn't go to
school for that and what ends up
happening is this constant back and
forth between your heart and your brain
when you're getting these motivated
moments when you want to do amazing
things and then your brain takes over
again and keeps you small and this is
the path that so many entrepreneurs go
on this roller coaster ride of up and
down and up and down and up and down and
up and down
sound familiar
it's time to get off the roller coaster
and start making progress on your dreams
today's video i'm going to show you how
so
yesterday i got asked on my live stream
evan what's the most important part of
your daily routine
and so many people have so many
different daily routines and and it's
easy to do the things like drink a glass
of water in the morning go outside and
get some sunlight and you know all of
these things but the most important
thing for me is actually having my
intention for the day i've actually been
experimenting with writing it out the
day before so this is this is what i
wrote last night of basically my entire
schedule
and then more than just what i'm going
to do more than just what i'm going to
do it's how i want to feel what's my
intention going into it so if i look at
this i'm supposed to be recording
espresso videos right now right that was
on my list 10 30 a.m record espresso
videos it's right there and here get a
head start even though you don't want to
recording videos at the beginning is
always difficult for me there's a couple
reasons why i'm i'm shy i'm introverted
i don't crave the spotlight i don't like
being in front of the camera
i don't i don't i don't do it for ego
purposes
and also i'm afraid i'm afraid
because i want it to be great i want
this video to be the next best video i i
don't want to disappoint people my
number one fear is going to be that i'll
disappoint somebody and so every time
you make something you risk
disappointing somebody where it's easier
just to stay small stay safe don't make
anything today and so it's on my list
the to-do right i think a lot of you if
you're watching this video you probably
have a list of to-do's but how many of
you are actually doing the things on
your list of to-do's
the hardest part of just getting started
already as i started recording this
video it's a lot easier to keep going
and recording more videos this is the
first one that i'm recording today and
so having that written down
get a head start even though you don't
want to
reminds me of who i want to be
and what i find so valuable about this
is i write this the night before
so the night before you know it's it's
11 o'clock at night i usually sit on the
floor and i review my calendar for the
next day and i write out what i'm going
to be doing and i've added how do i want
to feel what's my reminder to myself
before stepping into that task imagine
you're being your own high performance
coach sitting there telling yourself how
you want to feel remember your intention
before starting that next task
and i knew
okay evans is what you always do before
you make a video there's a little bit of
procrastination there's a little bit of
fear there's a little bit of slowness
there's a little bit of
not laziness but there's a little bit of
just apprehension before you get started
why because you don't want to start
because you're afraid because you don't
want to you don't want to support people
so i write down that message again get a
head start even though you don't want to
because i got a lot of stuff to do today
i got a lot of videos i need to record
today and if it takes me an hour
procrastination before i film that's a
lot of time wasted that could be doing
other things to help grow my business
and push my movement forward so this
this really helps and so when somebody
asks me what's the most important part
of my morning routine it's remembering
the intention how do i want today to go
not just having a list of to do's but
actually writing down how you want to
feel and that message to yourself to
give you the extra push that you need to
move it forward so how do you do it i'm
going to give you three different
suggestions i think will help you
shortcut that talk in your brain and get
you into action mode
the first thing is idea to action so
right away as soon as you get an idea
for something just take action on it we
spend so much time in our heads
overthinking over planning over
analyzing over researching over
preparing and then nothing happens
nothing gets created has that has that
ever happened to you you got this idea
that you think is genius and you spend
all this time over planning over
preparing overthinking and then you
never actually make anything
and then maybe a year or two goes by you
see someone else get rich off of your
idea
i'm still a recovering perfectionist
myself right i lost a 40 million deal
when i was 20 something
because i was just trying to be too
perfect and so teach yourself to
shortcut the brain out you got an idea
you're gonna do something about it if
the intention is positive if the if the
goal is to try to serve and to help
other people
idea action idea action idea action do
it
the second thing is come up with your
intentions
whether you want to do my method and the
night before write down your calendar
and how you want to feel or if it's just
a first thing in the morning you're
you're looking at your calendar that's
what i used to do before writing it down
i just pull up my phone
load my calendar and just see what was
on my list for today because i'd often
forget what am i doing today i don't
know i just woke up i'm tired i look at
my calendar and then with each one i
would just mentally go through instead
of writing it
how do i want to show up for this person
if i'm making youtube videos how do i
want to show up
on camera how do i want to show up for
my audience how do i want to show up for
you i would just mentally think about
that as i go through the day and i
basically wake up go to the bathroom
pull up my phone and start going through
my calendar
that's it and how i want to feel the
intention going through each individual
item on my calendar
what i love about this
is i find that i'm a little more
courageous at night compared to in the
morning i just had a day hopefully it
was a good day hopefully i served i
helped
it's often after i answer some questions
on instagram so i'm in the service heart
and mindset
and i think about how do i want to show
up tomorrow if you find that you have
more energy at night or more clarity or
more boldness at night then then do that
think about how do you want to show up
tomorrow what are your tasks write them
down and with each one just write down
what the intention is how do you want to
show up as a human for each one so not
just a list of to do's but how you want
to feel going into each one
look use even as an example every day at
2 30 i spend time with nina
okay
every day 2 30 take a break from
whatever i'm doing spend time with
neyman we usually go outside for the
walk with the dogs uh if it's raining
we'll stay inside and do something
together just a quick break in the
middle of the day to spend time together
and that's in my calendar and on my
calendar it says
2 30
half an hour break with nina
but i wrote down what's my intention
right so not just time with nina i wrote
down
have fun and make her feel loved
i wrote something else down yesterday
but that's my that's my intention for
today have fun and make her feel loved
so last night i wrote that down i'm
looking at nina she's lying in bed she's
you know about to fall asleep and i want
to think how do i want to show up for
her tomorrow for our break
have fun
and make her feel loved
so i look at that again this morning
and i look at it again right now
and then here's what's going to happen
at 2 30
2 30 i'm going to be done filming my
videos i'm going to look at my calendar
look at my sheet here let's say 2 30
time with nina have fun make her feel
loved
just that reminder
will make me show up differently
if your goal is to have fun if your goal
is to make somebody feel loved you're
going to show up slightly differently
i'm going to show up with more love with
more energy maybe pull in some kind of
joke maybe picking her up and turning
her in a circle something i'm going to
show up slightly different
because i reminded myself that it's not
just
a break
the intention is to have fun
and make her feel loved
and so if you do that for all of the
items on your calendar for every meeting
that you've got for every quiet time
that you got for every creative moment
that you've got how do you want to show
up if you can write it down i love the
night before and then under each one how
do you want to show up that prime
when you look at it just before you go
into the task will help you show up as
you'd like as your most bold courageous
proud self and then set number three is
have a routine that challenges you to be
a better human this is why i make these
videos honestly this espresso series is
supposed to be a morning series that we
release five days a week to help you
start your day with a shot of espresso
with with some love with some
encouragement with people who are doing
more than you you may never meet me you
may never meet john ashraf you may never
meet bill gates or oprah winfrey or
steve jobs or the people that i profile
on this channel but you can learn you
can learn from them i learn from them i
start my day being around them and the
more that you're around these people who
are living the life that you want that
have the belief systems that you want
you will start to adopt those as your
own as well because the people around
you probably aren't those people
right how many of the people around you
are the people that you look to and say
i want to be like that person that
person's got my life that person has my
ideal values that person is living the
life that i want to live
probably not
right and that's okay you can inspire
them to live a better life through your
actions but you need to get that push
and so the more you can create that
environment around you to help you get
it the greater the chances of you
actually going off and accomplishing
it's all in the mindset
when you get up in the morning you do
what you normally do
i would eventually a lot of you here
probably turn on your cell phones your
computers and what's the latest email
what's the latest text that comes in you
start your day off like that
that's your mindset
try this
get up in the morning do whatever you
have to do don't turn the computer on
don't turn the tv on go right back to
bed again either lay there or sit there
and just bring the universe to you
here's how you do it
you just be
it's virtually impossible when you first
do it because a thousand thoughts come
through your head we're human beings so
what you do is you're sitting in bed
look at the wall look at the off tv set
look at the ceiling look at the door
look at something in the room that gets
your attention
and just look at it and just be for a
couple minutes
not 10 minutes not 20 minutes not two
days just b when your mind wanders find
another spot in the room to look at so
you're back in present time even for a
couple of minutes
now go about your day don't think about
what you're gonna do for that split few
minutes you're now becoming part of a
universe which is also part of global
thinking all the things in the world
that you could say are like the secrets
that being positive is one of the
main things that people need to do how
did you happen on that in life
whether it's personal or people around
me when you see people that are positive
that look at something good and
something bad that took place
they move along in life faster they're
better and people want to be around
these people i mean too often people
gossip the one gossip person wants to be
around the other person that gossips but
they don't realize
when you gossip you're saying something
you heard about somebody else you're
telling everybody what if part of it was
wrong you're gonna go out and tell every
person you told this oh i'm sorry it was
wrong tell everybody you told it's not
going to happen so it's things to learn
about don't gossip don't belittle people
if you don't have to god please don't
try and look at the positive angle what
good could come out of something and
that positiveness is gonna make you live
longer
happier and wake up in the morning happy
not oh my god i gotta go to work i can't
wait till i get home i wanna retire
because people were not positive they
were not happy and what happens if they
retire they hate their job they retire
three or four years later they're dead
because they have nothing to do that
positive attitude be around positive
people encourage positiveness if you
find yourself walking around just
complaining all the time around people
that complain a lot man move or just try
and do something different change your
life being positive and a positive
attitude is find something positive and
something bad
makes you look for solutions when i was
down and out okay oh pop bottles let's
get the pop bottles cash them in you
want to have impact
uh
usually delegations important um
although you know individual
contributors in terms of inventing a
drug or a new approach to things
that's phenomenal so when microsoft
first got started i wrote most the code
and everybody else's code i read and
kind of rewrote uh and
that got us up to 10 people and then i
had to say to myself okay we're going to
ship code that i didn't edit
and that was hard for me uh but you know
i kind of got over that then i still
said okay i'm gonna interview everyone
and i'm gonna at least look at samples
of their code well that got us up to
about 40 people
and that was at a point where
i had sold way more software than we
could write uh because everybody was so
impressed and i thought well i need to
keep enough collect enough money
to you know keep hiring all these people
but uh the demand was so high that you
know we were actually falling behind
that's when i hired steve
and steve figured out a
uh
how to control what promises i made to
people uh and b how to hire lots of
people and good really good people and
create organizations and teams so i
delegated to steve that and he was
constantly saying to me okay we're gonna
hire programmers that you've never met
and i'd say no or not and then
he would show me numerically that the
constraint wasn't gonna work uh you know
so uh then i said okay then i would you
know know all the managers of the people
and so over time
uh and of course
you know i could say the quality per
person was falling monotonically
according to me
but you know large problems
uh if you want to you know write the
most popular
office productivity software that one
person absolutely can't do that you can
write pretty code so everyone has to
decide
what scale of organization they want to
work in eventually
you know my role was very much as a
leader and a reviewer of managers but
the top people and i hired some super
experienced people
uh i would make sure they were pursuing
a common vision and they were well
coordinated but in terms of a lot of
management stuff they were way better
than i was now i had to have the
framework
to know what mix of skills that we
needed and you know when they were
working well enough together but a lot
of uh
you know my
value adam was picking
say to do graphics user interface or to
do an integrated office uh type thing or
to go global and not use agents to have
microsoft be present all over the world
and
so yeah picking what you're good at and
how you find the other people
uh to fill in those things that's super
important and most founders don't aren't
able to scale that up and kind of give
up
the hands-on things that they used to
get a lot of uh pleasure and comfort
from you are here with your daughter who
is 21 right and you were 21 when you
became a billionaire is that right
almost yeah all right so around that age
were you were like the youngest person
to become a billionaire is that right
for you
yeah in terms of my own earning it on my
own yeah right okay so which is the most
important thing yeah so did you when you
were a kid did you
did you care about money or you just
cared about technology and that's it
just happened
uh mostly i love software
uh i do remember the private school i
went to there were other kids whose
families were better off like they had a
porsche or something but it wasn't that
that big of a deal my thing was that i
just loved doing software i loved hiring
people and i was stunned when it ended
up being so valuable
really yeah
it surprised you yeah because i always
had to be careful
that we wouldn't hire too many people i
was always worried because i was people
who worked for me were older than me and
they had kids and i always thought what
if we don't get paid will i be able to
meet the payroll so i was always very
conservative about the finances and then
when we did go uh public uh was i uh
30 by then uh then i was kind of stunned
at what it multiplied out to and
everybody has a different talent
and the reason we're all so messed up is
because you're looking at everybody
else's talent
and wishing you had some of their talent
all the energy that you spend thinking
about wishing about being jealous of
envious of anybody else is energy that
you're not only putting out is going to
come back to you negatively but you're
taking that away from you
all your energy should be forced on what
do i have to offer what do i have to
give how can i be used in service
because dr king's message of not
everybody can be famous
but everybody can be great because
greatness is determined by service and
there is not a job in here that you can
do that you don't switch the paradigm to
service
and not make that job more fulfilling i
don't care what the job is if you say
i'm a singer i'm a dancer i'm an artist
i'm a teacher i'm a nurse i'm a doctor
i'm a janitor i'm a i'm a clerk but if
you say if i look at this from how do i
use this in service to something bigger
than myself
it no longer becomes a job it becomes an
offering to the world if i leave you
with nothing else it's just know this
for sure
there is not one
thing
that has ever happened to you
not one experience not one encounter not
one crisis not one joyful thing that
hasn't
happened
just to make you better and help you
rise
every single thing you're calling in
whether you know it or not when you
figure out that you are calling it in
when you actually start meditating or
praying or doing or having a spiritual
practice which is the number one thing
you need if you want to be successful in
the world you need something that gives
back and nourishes you
regardless of what you call that you
need to you need to fill your cup so
that you can be so full your cup runneth
over and you have enough to give to
other people if you don't fill your cup
you end up dried up
you end up tired exhausted and don't
have enough to give to other people you
end up resentful every time somebody
asks you because your cup is empty and
now they want some of yours
so your number one job your number one
job is to fill your cup and make
yourself whole
that's your job we've got to try to
create an electric car company but it
wasn't as though in creating these
companies that we thought that we would
be successful
i thought that the most likely outcome
was failure
but
but it was still worth doing even though
the odds of success were low in fact
even for for sport spacex
the
originally what i started doing was not
creating a rocket company but but
actually was going to do
a small mission to mars which was just a
philanthropic mission where you would
send a small greenhouse with seeds and
dehydrated gel in the wood
upon landing hydrate the gel and you'd
have
this cool picture of green plants on a
red background and the public tends to
respond to precedence and superlatives
so this would be the first life on mars
furthest that life's ever traveled
and you'd have this great money shot of
green plants on the right background and
if you want to make progress in things
i think that
the
the best analytical framework
for
understanding the future is physics
um i'd recommend studying
the
uh
the thinking process around physics like
not just not not the equations i mean
equations certainly they're helpful but
the the the way of thinking in physics
is
it's the best framework for
understanding things that are
counterintuitive
and
you know always taking the position that
you are some degree wrong
and your goal is to be less wrong over
time
one of the biggest mistakes people
generally make and i'm guilty of it too
is wishful thinking
you know like you want something to be
true
even if it isn't true um
and so you ignore the things that
uh you ignore the real truth because of
what you want to be true
um
this is a very difficult trap to avoid
um and like i said certainly one that i
i find myself in
having problems with
but if you just take that approach of
you're always to some degree wrong and
your goal is to be less wrong
and and solicit critical feedback
particularly from friends
like friends particularly friends if
somebody loves you they want the best
for you
they don't want to tell you the bad
things
um
so you have to ask them
okay you know and said really i really
do want to know
and then they'll tell you i spent an
unusual amount of time with my
grandparents and especially with my
grandfather on the ranch so he had a
ranch in south texas
and i would spend my summers there from
age 4 to 16. and they when i was four
they were taking me for the summer to
kind of give my parents a break
you know sort of because they were so
young
um and it was useful i was a handful i'm
sure
and uh and anyway
he he he he created the illusion for me
when i was four years old that i was
helping him on the ranch
which of course could not have been true
but i believed it
and um and then as by the time i was 16
of course i was actually helping on the
ranch i you know i could i can fix
prolapsed cattle i can you know we did
all of our own veterinary work some of
the cattle even survived
and we fixed windmills and laid you know
water pipelines and built fences and
barns and fixed that fixed the bulldozer
that you guys talked about
and so one of the things that's so
interesting about that lifestyle and
about my grandfather is he did
everything himself you know he didn't
call a vet if one of the animals was
sick he figured out what to do himself
and
uh so what does it mean no delegation
being resourceful i think is the you
know that you can always you can't if
there's a problem
there's a solution everything i've ever
done
has started small
amazon started
with a couple of people
and
blue origin started with
five people
and the budget of bloorigin was very
very small now the budget of blue
origins approaches a billion dollars a
year and next year it'll be more than a
billion dollars in amazon it literally
was 10 people today it's half a million
people but you it's hard to remember for
you guys but for me it's like yesterday
i was driving the
packages to the post office myself
and
hoping one day we could afford a
forklift and so but so for me i've seen
small things get big and it's part of
this day one mentality i like treating
things as if if they're small you know
amazon even though it is a large company
i wanted to have the heart and spirit of
a small one people like us
we are getting used to be criticized
we are getting used to be said
no people say
no to you
when people say yes to you
we really appreciate because it's not
you know why people should say yes to
you you have to prove
so
as the entrepreneur
you have to get used to be
challenged
have to get used to be said no by the
other people by the found by the
investors by your customers by the
people but this
this is the opportunity
when everybody believe it you have no
chance when only few people believe it
you believe it you prove it that's your
chance kfc has refused to hire you
so
uh
with all these uh know
how at the end of the day what has been
the driver which has made you who you
are
yeah i wish people could say yes to me
but if they say yes i have no choice i
have to accept it
and
of course you're not happy when people
say no
have a good sleep wake up try it again
it's always my fault not the other
people's part why you can convince
people if you cannot prove it
but the thing is that
very important there are two group of
people you have to convincing first
group people your team
they believe in you
they trust in you and they believe the
things we agreed together
and second is uh your customers they
really love your products
and investors it's okay ted williams
wrote a book called the science of
hitting and ended he had a picture of
himself at bat and the strike zone
broken into i think 77 squares
and he said if he waited for the pitch
that was really in his sweet spot he
would bat 400 and if he had to swing at
something on the lower corner he would
probably bat 235
and in investing i'm in a no called
strike business which is the best
business you can be in
i can look at a thousand different
companies and i don't have to be right
on every one of them or even 50 of them
so i can pick the ball i want to hit
and the trick in investing is just to
sit there and watch pitch after pitch go
by
and wait for the one right in your sweet
spot and if people are yelling swing you
bum ignore them
there's a temptation for people to act
far too frequently in stock simply
because they're so liquid
over the years you develop a lot of
filters and i do know what i call my
circle of competence so i i stay within
that circle the allowance when i was a
little boy was a nickel a week but i
like the idea of
having a little more than a nickel a
week to work with and i went into
business very early
i started selling coca-cola door-to-door
i sold gum door-to-door or sold saturday
in post liberty magazine ladies home
journal you name it
[Music]
i think i enjoyed the game almost right
from the start
but i like being my own boss
that's one thing i like about delivering
papers
[Music]
i could arrange the route i wanted
nobody was bothering me at five or six
in the morning
[Music]
i was delivering 500 papers a day and i
made a penny of paper but in terms of
compounding
that penny turned into something else
there's this culture in silicon valley
that kind of
makes startups seem glamorous and
i never really believed that right i
never had a goal of starting a startup
and
my goal when i realized that i had a
company was to get it to be a good
company as quickly as possible right and
kind of get out of what you'd call the
like risky startup phase where you are
just like constantly about to die and
where you could get to a point where you
can actually do some interesting things
and make make a lot of more interesting
bets and um
so i don't know i never read a lot of
the literature on this and i mean maybe
if i had then i would have made so many
mistakes but so i don't know if like if
learning for me is the right way to go
on this but i mean but it did
i think your model must have come from
somewhere though even if it was even if
you it was unintentional right like were
you influenced by peter thiel or sean
well yes people see all these people
once i met them i actually i hadn't
really heard of peter thiel before i'm
talking about
yeah right yeah but he was massively
influential on my thinking right i mean
like a lot of the
uh the early lessons that i took on how
to think about strategy came from peter
and sean and
um i did pay a lot of attention when i
was growing up to microsoft i thought
i mean i grew up you know using you know
windows 3.1 and then windows 95 and i
just thought that those were like the
most unbelievable things many aspiring
entrepreneurs even in this room struggle
to find their initial idea
how do you constantly find ways to
invent new products and where does your
inspiration come from
um you know i
um
i mean i think of a lot of ideas at
traffic lights
i think of them all the time in
different places and i think it's part
of just being hyper observant
i um i like to find white space i pay
attention to what are things that
haven't evolved and why
you know like there's certain things in
our society that updates itself and
changes and and you know constantly and
then there's certain things that it's
not and so i'll ask myself questions all
day every day it's just the way my brain
works like i could even be looking at a
table and be like why is the table like
that when was the table first created is
that the actual best design for a table
or could there be something different
and you know spanx went into men's and
that was
randomly how that happened was because i
got curious that the man's undershirt
was created in 1918 and no one had paid
any attention to it since it was
literally the same thing and so i just
you know talked to my brother and my
husband about it and their undershirts
that the necks stretched out or they
were boxy and bulky under clothes and i
thought oh i'm just going to add a
little bit of lycra to the cotton
undershirt for men and so the neck won't
stretch out and i'm going to taper it in
at the waist my assistant who's my right
hand lisa she's been my right hand for
16 years can attest to this but i have
99 pages i don't know why it's 99 but
she told me the other day it's 99 pages
single space type of ideas
i need one more idea so um i i think of
ideas constantly on airplanes and car
you know talking to somebody and i email
it to myself and then i just keep them
and log them my dream is for there to be
many more female inventors i'm hoping
more more and more women will have the
courage to
take that risk it's a risk to invent
something you have to risk being made
fun of you have to risk looking like an
idiot
you have to do something that didn't
already exist which is scary i mean my
brain told me a million times who do you
think you are coming up with this then
one day you wake up and you go well what
if it is me during my california springs
and summers i spent most of my days in
the high sierras in yosemite valley
working
as a river guide
and a rock climbing instructor
i loved those jobs
but unfortunately they didn't pay that
well
so i also got a job working a couple of
days a week as a computer programmer
back in berkeley
i learned a program in college
i didn't love programming
but it was fun
and i was good at it
and computer program programming gave me
the same kind of satisfaction
as solving math problems and playing
chess
both things i enjoyed before before i
became a confused teenager
at this point in my life
i thought i was making real progress on
my journey of self-discovery
i had found a cause
i had a couple of jobs that i love
and one that was fun and paid the bills
i was pretty happy with my life
my wife was not
what she saw was a college dropout who
spent too much time in the mountains
doing foolish things
she wanted me to work full time as a
computer programmer or go back to
college and finish my degree
we compromised
sort of
i started taking classes at uc berkeley
i took several classes but the only one
i can remember was a sailing class
taught at berkeley marina
once again i fell in love and began a
lifelong affair
with the limitless omnipotent pacific
ocean
when my class was over i wanted to buy a
sailboat
my wife said
this was the single stupidest idea she
had ever heard in her entire life
she accused me of being irresponsible
and she told me i lacked ambition
she kicked me out
and then she divorced me
this was a pivotal moment in my life
[Applause]
my family was still mad at me for not
going to medical school
and now my wife was divorcing me because
i lacked ambition
it looked like a reoccurrence of the
same old problem
once again i was unable to live up to
the expectations of others
but this time
i was not disappointed in myself
for failing to be
the person they thought i should be
their dreams
and my dreams were different
i would never confuse the two of them
again i don't think my personality has
changed much since i was five years old
uh i think
as i explained to the kids just a little
while ago
uh probably the single
most
important aspect of my personality and
as far as determining my success has
been my
my questioning of conventional wisdom my
doubting of experts just because they're
experts
and questioning of authority
and while that can be very very painful
in terms of your relationship with your
parents and your relationship with your
teachers it's enormously useful in life
and i'm gonna tell you something that a
lot of people 99 of people disagree with
me on
right everybody says follow your
passions
i say this
right i say follow your effort
it's amazing how we're all passionate
about things
we are all passionate about something
helping veterans helping this
organization helping this group that's
great
but
no matter what it all nets out to where
do you put your time
because when people put in their time
you get better at things and when you
get better at something and get good at
something then you have a chance to be
great at something and you know what
i've learned nobody ever quits anything
they're great at
and once you get great at it it's
amazing how passionate you become about
it
follow your efforts
right because it's not in the dreaming
it's in the doing what is your thing and
when did you kind of understand what it
was it hasn't changed my thing is
learning learning whatever is new and
applying it in ways that other people
aren't thinking of and so when i started
i got fired from a job selling software
started a company and within six months
this was the early days of pcs i
recognized that okay we need to connect
pcs together back then you walked around
and you had your five and a quarter inch
floppy and you know who would need to
connect to pc we started you know
writing software for local area networks
became a systems integrator 30 some
million dollar run rate and sold it to h
r block and then got to the internet
okay let's look at this internet thing
someone's going to need to put audio and
then video on there great and then after
yahoo did yahoo right i'm like you know
what i'm looking at these big screen tvs
that cost thirty thousand dollars that
are high definition television sets and
i'm thinking you know what eventually
they're gonna follow the price
performance curve of traditional of
traditional um consumer electronics and
they're going to come down to price so i
started the first all high definition tv
network called hdnet then i'm looking
and saying okay you know what it's like
2006 2007 and traditional television and
cable is going um digital i'm saying you
know what there's going to be more a lot
of storage space and first access
digital space that cable companies
aren't used to using so let's take a
movie production company that we created
and let's make it available for day and
date distribution where people can will
pay 20 bucks
to the the cable company to watch this
brand new movie and we get to keep 10 of
it and so we
had 29 29 productions we started
producing movies and lo and behold the
first movie we created was a documentary
called enron the smartest guys in the
room you talked about
companies having a unique advantage can
you speak more on that for me please
sure i mean
what is it that that a customer can get
from you that they can't get from
anybody else
and you have to be very careful with
that too when i just talked about lying
to yourself as an entrepreneur
because often we'll say well it's just
like uber but it has pink cars uber
doesn't have pink cars
that that's a difference without a
distinction right
lots of times people get confused
between what's a product and what's a
feature
pink uber cars
that's a feature that's not a unique
product
excuse me so you have to know what it is
that you do
that is so unique people's the people
your potential customers say whoa
i did not know that as opposed to well
let me go tell uber that they should
probably add pink cars
because whenever you're competing with
them you know all of you are going to
compete with amazon at some point
if you're not already
just the reality
and so you've got to understand when
amazon starts looking at my customer
base what is it that i can convey to
them that makes me unique and that's
that's what i meant by unique difference
the general theme i would suggest is
that all trends
um are overrated
and so
if you think about current uh trends in
technology uh you know uh
uh
healthcare i.t software education
software
overrated sas enterprise software really
overrated um
big data cloud computing if you hear
those words you need to think fraud you
need to run away as fast as you possibly
can
and um and the reason these buzzwords
um
tell you that something um is that
there's these buzzwords they're sort of
like a tell in poker that people are
bluffing and that there's nothing that
there's uh that the business is not
undifferentiated because the buzz words
tell you that it is one company of a
category that's undifferentiated from
the others in that category and
therefore uh are symptomatic somehow of
of um a lot of competition and a bad a
bad business idea and so you know you
don't want to be the fourth online pet
food company you don't want to be the
10th thin film solar panel company you
don't want to be the 1000th restaurant
in san francisco and so there is
something about if you can describe
what a company is doing
very straightforwardly by referencing
these these buzzwords these categories
that already exist
that's actually a sign that it's a
pretty bad uh that's that's a pretty bad
idea i think there's a problem in in
western europe where
where failure is uh
it's it's too impossible to fail once
you fail you can never you can never
start over i think there's a there's an
opposite version of this in california
where i think sometimes people
are a little bit too facile about
failure because i i think it actually is
always incredibly damaging to people um
and if you work really hard at something
and it doesn't work um
uh that's you know that's that's going
to be psychologically damaging you know
people have less confidence you all
sorts of reasons why why that tends to
be uh that tends to be quite bad i think
that um i think when people
i don't think there's that much you
learn from failure by the way because um
it's it's typically over determined it's
like why is technology slowing down why
did you fail it's typically five
separate reasons you worked with the
wrong people the idea was bad the timing
was wrong it wasn't a monopoly the
product didn't work
and okay next time i'm working with
different people you figure out one out
of the five things you're likely to fail
fail again so i think i think failure is
not something one can learn very much
from i think that's sort of a myth that
i i would challenge
um but what i think what i think you
should do when you when when something
goes badly wrong is um you just keep
going uh you you do something else
and you don't dwell on the past nobody's
got more haters than that but it stops a
lot of people and it doesn't stop you
yeah because because because i i you
know it's a different
for me
like
i understand
that
if you get if you're going to get
success
you're going to get the haters that's
the price
or one of the costs that's one of the
prices okay so because it goes back to
what i said earlier
all haters
first of all we should not admire haters
the way we do we even call them haters
they're not haters
they're quitters
they're quitters all haters are quitters
like this should be this should be the
title of your your thing is the all
haters
all haters yeah including me anytime i
hate on something
okay
i am i quit on that thing like i hate
drugs i quit drugs i hate drugs i hate
people that use drugs i don't trust
people that use drugs like no drug is
safe for me
and and i know i believe that no drug is
safe for other people now some people
can be like no no i'm using cannabis
recreational it's cool man i use
psychedelics and i do this good dude i
hate drugs i want to make it clear i
hate drugs and i i hate drugs for you
and i hate trucks for him i hate drugs
for everybody so i can be wrong but
right now i'm gonna hate drugs why
because i quit drugs
now if you're hating on grant cardone
and i hadn't done anything to you i'm
over here minding my own business or
building my own business
you know minding micromanaging my own
business so it grows so so if i'm doing
that okay and you're hating on me why
are you hating on me
now he uses social media too much these
are every example i go over it's because
you don't use it enough he works too
much because you don't use you don't
work enough
he doesn't spend enough time with his
kids you don't even have kids like i got
people hating on me
because i got my kids on my plane oh
you're gonna ruin your kids
if i'm gonna ruin my kids i'm gonna ruin
them private
you know so so um what are you quitting
on like so i it's very very important
for me like when i hate on somebody i
need to understand
did i quit on something or am i
legitimately hating on this person
for a reason because i'm trying to make
a i'm trying to make a statement
publicly and there are
there are people i publicly hate on and
why do you do that
uh because i want to make it clear that
they should not be doing business with
this person they should not be admiring
this person they should not
like as an opinion leader i think i have
some responsibility to tell people do
you you don't want to follow that if
you're going to follow him don't follow
me yeah
you can't follow both of us
and think that you're going to get any
place which is a huge problem today with
social media what do you think it'll
take for you to get over insecurity
moving forward
i'm not trying to you're not trying i'm
not trying to
i thought you said if you could get rid
of it you'd be able to do bigger the
unbelievable but but it's not it's not
it's not a target i have
letting go of insecurity no i think it's
just a human condition i think it's part
of the game i think it's part of being a
human being any more than i want to get
rid of my arms you know or my legs or
my arms and my legs my body my body is a
limitation
yeah you know so um
how do you manage it better than like
for people that are saying i you know i
want a 10x but i always have insecurity
and fear that i'm going to fail and
people are going to show up and yeah the
deal is going i'm going to go broke
how do you personally
get a conversation to yourself to the
insecurity and fear yeah it's not stop
it's come
you know for me for me fear fear the
things i i'm scared of i'm like
come on
you know that it's calling me says hey
come play over here
it's an indicator it's a good indicator
not a bad indicator lean into it lean
into come play with me okay so i either
have fear because it's really dangerous
and stupid
or like physically dangerous yeah let me
get to the edge of this thing i'm gonna
get on the other side of that thing i'm
probably gonna be scared yeah now why
why am i gonna be scared though
like
because i don't know what it feels like
to fall
you know this many floors and hit yeah
maybe it does maybe there's no big deal
about maybe dying is not even a big deal
right but i don't have the exp i don't
consciously have the experience
so
you know i used to be like
i can't buy a 78 000 house i was
terrified the first house i
i don't know what i'm doing because
you're not experienced i don't have the
experience man
this this is the problem and you're not
going to have the experience if you
don't move through the fear
and
a lot of people do it once and then they
don't do it again you got like
it's not going away yeah it's just gonna
you're gonna get used to
you're gonna get used to the ski boots
you know the first time you put them on
man they're freaking banging your shins
like i can't mend
but you just
wear into them
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want even more lessons from billionaires
check the video right there next to me i
think you'll love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there i became
terrified of public speaking and uh i
just couldn't do it we don't love this
product but we think others will love it
you know that's not really how it works
if you don't love it don't expect others
will either your relationship with time